austin both
four games three starts career against
the mets one and two with a five seven
four era robinson canoe is d.h today
crosses body with a tremendous play and
a throw then he goes over and covers
third in case brandon nimmo continues on
but josh harrison going
into left field thrown across his body
trey turner almost ran into the throw to
cover second base watch this
right over his head and then josh just
keeps going to where he's supposed to be
at third base here's alonso
gets this one to deep left field forget
that
another home run a monstrous shot by
alonso another laser beam off the bat
and pete is
closing this season with an absolute
howitzer that's his 15th home run of the
year and that might have been the
hardest hit one of all the beardless
giorme
lined the other way by guillermo and
he's got to base it that heads toward
the gap it'll go all the way back to the
wall we're almost to third he'll be held
up there and guillerme stands at second
with a well-struck double andrew
stevenson 13 hits in his 11-game streak
i'm making a 12-game streak and that's a
gapper
andrew stevenson
and now he has extra base hits in eight
of his last nine games
with authority to left center ball is
roasted
yadiel hernandez with a fly ball to left
center
plenty deep to score andrew stevenson
so the trey turner fly ball and andrew
running to third pays off yadiel has his
sixth rbi
in his 12th big league baltimore 2-1
game guillermo herrera leads off in the
second
radio drives one to deep left field
stevenson takes a look and it's out of
here
a long home run for guillermo herrera
his second as a met
and the mets now lead it three to one
the mets with home runs in each of the
first two innings bottom of the second
inning matt's three nats one so seth
lugo has his hands full with a hot
hitter
and the bases are jammed here's the o2
and stevenson pulls it hard beyond pete
alonso
he's digging for two
he's in there with another extra base
hit and the game is tied
andrew stevenson is amazing
and when you're hot you're hot you're
finding all the holes beth lugo now has
to deal with trey turner
turner rips one
and this should bring in two robles
stevenson behind him and the nats lead
5-3
36 rbis now for trey turner back up the
middle
two more score
so juan soto five percentage points
ahead of him 346.
soto that's going to get through for a
base hit
trey turner heads for third and juan
soto just took a big step in the batting
race one for one today seth lugo is
going to go up an inning and a third
bottom of the third inning the mets are
going to try steven matz now drew
stevenson
fourth walk in a row and it's seven to
three here's turner swinging a fly ball
left center field this one is deep it's
way back toward the track and it is gone
the nationals first grand slam of the
season belongs to trey turner
trey turner c
u later
a line drive just over the left center
field wall home run number 12.
turner has six rbis in the ball game and
the nationals lead it 11-3 john gomez
over one with a sack fly
and maybe more deep left center yon
gomes
see
you later
his fourth of the year
and it's 12-3
and the mets four were in the top of the
fifth inning
swing and a miss 93 away
strikeout number four and two outs
i really commanded the glove side
fastball well today wilson ramos fanned
in the second swinging after a single to
right center
in the first
and then ramos reaching for the breaking
ball one hopper garcia knows he has
plenty of time to set turns out to be a
pretty solid five innings for austin
vote bottom of the sixth inning and ace
is loaded on two more walks in this
inning luis garcia
and garcia is going to bust up his over
with that drive to right center
he'll bring in two more
and it's 14
to four
that's a feel good knock for luis garcia
he got a slider up got on top of it
nicely two more score and the line is
moving it's
a route here in d.c on the last day of
the season 15 of the minutes todd
frazier coming up 2-2
swing and a miss
and the 2020 season is all over
the gnats win seven of their last nine
they finish it off with a six and two
home stand